how are you able to hold them off down
the stretch
I mean they fought you know they test us
they push the ball they may shots late
uh
they switches now we stayed disciplined
even when they went on runs we're
airport adjustment game and uh make a
necessary adjustments so I thought we
did a good job executing you see you
seem exhausted you played the entire
second half I know you haven't been
feeling great how are you feeling right
now I feel better we won you know a
Winner's a win so
I'm good after this you know
it went off in the fourth quarter 23
points just what changed for you in that
fourth quarter
uh just lock it in yo I miss some really
good looks in the first half
[Applause]
my team told you to keep shooting I was
getting the looks I wanted uh we knew we
didn't fall so
good thing is I didn't stop shooting you
know team kept founding me and I was
able to knock him down down the streets
headed to La up 2-0 what do you expect
in game three to be like oh the crowd's
gonna be into it uh they're gonna run
they're gonna play with a lot of pace a
lot of energy
runs
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
Jamal Murray the 26 year old from
Ontario will a special performance
and Denver will head to Los Angeles with
a two-nothing lead
and Saturday game three Western
Conference Finals who